hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood
to remind you of where we are we're just
leaving the village we need to go back
to the house
i'm saying this to remind myself more
than to remind you we need to go back to
the house drop off all the delightful
goodies that we have of which we have
many many many many new delightful
delightful goodies
and then we need to find a chain or
trade for a chain to repair the well
in the village to talk to a man who's
going to give us a key so that a
boy who plays the violin boy
kid i have no idea someone demon
can uh woo his woman who is
lixian replay just the encapsulation of
her beauty
that we saw through the window there
[Music]
just beautiful oh that almost
rotted away completely i don't know if
its potency goes down
when it rots um bone away potatoes away
i don't think those are cookable the gun
parts for now oh
next to the ammo that we have yes please
put the
jars of meat away oh god do not use
those
i don't have scrap metal that's the one
thing i did not get is scrap metal
oh man this is full that's weird it's
full well i'm gonna sell a lot of this
stuff to the dude
when he comes by tomorrow morning but
for now this is sitting really nice
it's okay we there's still time in the
day there's still time in the day
to get some stuff done oh wait i can go
to the wolf camp right now
i don't have to wait i can trade i'm an
idiot does he have a chain
that is the question do i want to get is
he
would he have the chain he doesn't want
to buy most of his stuff that i have
anyway he would want to buy weapons so
let's forget that avenue let's not go
down that path
let's go to that camp where those um
dudes were let's beat them up and then
let's see about stealing the stuff that
they're trying to steal
well that they don't know that they
should steal because they don't
understand its
value now where was it oh
hey mushies handy that i don't like that
sound
where was that camp not the wolf's camp
the little camp i came across it ah
there it is
oh if i had rocks i could distract him
let's do it oh boy here we go
yeah i gotta swing before
i get to him yeah swing before i get to
him that's what really does it
come at me bro
oh that's got range too that's got range
that i didn't assume it had but it's got
range
okay i just gotta get this guy done
alcohol rags yes please okay
corpse rag love it backpack
oh oh my god i love it
oh this was incredibly worth it
shoes what's in your shoes show me
what's in your shoes
i want to see your shoes all right we
are sitting
so gosh darn pretty
rags yes it's it's hard to see like the
clothes
the small details on the ground that's
the good stuff that is the good stuff
i didn't even have to use my abilities
oh
do i wanna open that i have two luck
yeah i think i'm okay to open that
just gas and nails pathetic that was not
worth it
if i was that's what the hell
what what what killed it
interesting very interesting all of this
is very very very very interesting
[Music]
i don't know what that's about someone's
really sad oh
i could make a piss oh my god
yeah yeah let me think about it
i have this i have two pistol clips do i
are there any bullets in the clips
that's what i don't know i'm gonna
assume there are
yes yes yes give pistol pistol
yes yes yes
yes repair my shovel repair shovel
yes okay let's put gas in the generator
before i freak out completely
ah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay all right wardrobe there's not even
a wardrobe left
wardrobe more like a wuzz drobe
[Music]
ah this somehow got moved okay
so this is fantastic i just need to
board up the last
door down here this is a phenomenon
this is phenomena this is for new me
i don't have company tonight so uh it's
a little less a little less fun
light armor oh i oh my goodness light i
can't make it yet
obviously oddly enough you know i my my
fear now is i'm gonna swing this and i'm
gonna hit this lamp
and it's gonna break i i don't think it
would break but
for some reason i feel like it will i
should just put it in the corner
i should bring that other lamp in here
and just put both of them
cause this is the only room that i stay
in i should move this chair to the
ho ho ho wow whoa whoa whoa i'm sorry i
moved the furniture
oh i'm sorry i moved it
i didn't mean to move it you move it
back wherever you want to move it
i'm sorry that i was being picky about
the movement of the furniture
okay uh you know even though i'm
assuming that you really like this
positioning of it
rather have it in the corner it's out of
the way
of what i'm trying to accomplish oh
hi oh you're gonna you're gonna get in
trouble there
hey bud how you doing hey come on in
why am i even bothering with the shovel
with that guy
okay oh you had some goodies on you no
window please barricade please
and scrap metal put this crap metal away
that guy had some goodies
what what i'm sorry oh
i'm sorry what the hell
okay thanks for the thank you i
actually needed that but what the hell
for the armor but i don't i i mean i
can't
make it yet oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
what the hell what is happening oh my
god get away
why am i using my shovel for this i need
to use like the stick or something
you know what actually i'm just gonna
use put the shovel down there
uh hell okay another night survived
what the hell what the hell
okay hey bud how are you doing okay good
you got some inventory space
you got fabric i'm definitely going to
take that off your hands oh let me
hand let me just get this all sorted
this takes a while just because i gotta
plan it
um do you want the meat jars you know
what i don't know what they're for yet
so i'm not gonna get rid of them
just because they might be something
important
uh glass bottle they're probably high
value
they're about 50 a pop so that's pretty
good but it's a lot of space
uh sure that gives me 350.
i will take these wires and these rags
and they'll clear up some space for you
it really is just like a dance of
inventory space i'll also take the scrap
metal
the mushroom the knife i'm gonna sell
the knife to the wolf
uh because he takes weapons more than
anything i am gonna take a run
to the wolf after this i could sell them
some torches they
they torches are high value too torch
torch bandages with alcohol i only need
the one
shell so technically speaking i could
sell three shells
this pill these potatoes perfect good
you know actually fabric i i love fabric
being able to have better inventory in
like another slot here is
super valuable i am going to actually oh
i can't upgrade my inventory anymore i'm
at max
i'm at max inv ah all right it's fine
this is good i'm gonna keep that shell
because i'm gonna need it so now what
i'm gonna do
is i'm going to plan to go to the wolf
guy i'm gonna bring the knife to sell
the medium caliber magazine to sell
because i only just got the pistol i
don't think i'm gonna be getting a
rifle anytime soon pellet gun i didn't
even have a chance for that one
these sticks i'll sell uh and then the
meat
i'll sell two of them the bone maybe
the wolf would like the bone i don't
know okay and i've got plenty of
gasoline i could actually sell
the gasoline i don't need this much no
he doesn't even have any space
but he's got 148 reputation so i might
as well get some stuff oh
small caliber magazine yes i need that
okay
now we're good there's this door still
intact wow that bathtub really got moved
i'm gonna use the window then i don't
know why it's so stressful
every time it feels like i'm planning
for war every single time i get this one
break in the morning
and i know it you guys don't see much of
it but it's like a lot of
kerfuffle okay it's directly up there
past the mushroom
the camp it's not nearly the camp it's
actually before the silo
okay let's do this
hey bud what you doing there
well ah there's oh hey there's more than
one of you okay
you know i'll fight sure yeah i'll fight
come on
wow oh [ __ ] god damn it
okay he's dead but you just had rocks
really
oh my god you suck
i don't know what that guy's doing let's
just
okay he had nothing wired yes
that's valuable shiny stone yeah that's
also valuable
i don't know if wolf will want that hole
a body of some savage lies in this hole
now i kind of feel bad you guys were
kind of just doing your own thing
i just came in and killed you a little
rude of me
hey buddy guess who's got a pistol now
who
i joined the big boy club i have you
know what the bone
all right whatever this this this this
this this
except excellent deal i need the chain
the meat the shiny stone i just picked
up you can do the wire
the pistol magazine the rags she red
chicken egg i don't know what the
red is that special all right whatever
these are what i need uh i have two
pipes i'm not gonna get another until i
know i need it
all right cool hey buddy hey buddy buddy
this is for you i'll just leave it there
i know it's probably like
indignatious that's not the right word
but yeah you probably don't know what it
even means
indignified for me to offer it to you
directly i'll just leave it there and
back away slowly all right you enjoy
that
you'll enjoy that all right my shovel is
looking bad but i do have a chain i
could go to the village right now
yeah actually let's just go ahead and do
that and see if that's actually what i
needed to do
i feel like i'm making actually like
good progress
i got the chain i got a good handle on
my inventory
i've got weapons i've got a pistol now
which i've never used before
but it'll be interesting which hopefully
this means that i could take on some of
the i don't have like an ammo counter or
anything
that would be too convenient what is
happening over here
oh it's the dude slamming his head
quickly give him the old
what for oh he ran away all right
whatever
you live to die another day my friend
do i want to bother opening this i mean
i've got extras and i can always buy
extras so
that's not bad that's not a bad hole
that's not bad
yeah some crates are definitely worth
more than others but i guess it is just
a crap shoot if you've got extra go for
it which i
do so i will where there's your well
let me fix this up for you there you go
buddy
hey tada
so
that's not what i was thinking was gonna
happen that's not the outcome that i had
determined
well thank you for the torch that's very
nice the flares are also a good touch
i'll leave you my logs
and my wood these matches and i will
come back for them if i'm alive which i
they'll take the nails too actually keep
the flares right there
if they gave him to me there's probably
a good reason for it right
right yes the haunted well of
nightmares oh my god yep let me get the
torch out
hey bud oh god i wish i had my lantern i
wish i had my lantern
i really wish i had my lantern oh i wish
i had my lantern
oh cause my lantern would free up by
hand
at least lots of mushrooms that's nice
that's really nice
that's not so nice that one that one not
as nice
oh and not not nearly as nice
oh it's so quiet oh i hate the quiet
it's never been quiet in this game
oh no oh no
what was it what was that what was it
quiet about
what did you just decided to hush down a
little bit
it was getting a little too noisy did we
pass into the library section of the
well
oh no no no no
oh no that is one of the big
yeah where's my ability where's my
ability run
i'm running i'm running i'm running
i'm running hello
i will shoot you yeah i'm going to
definitely use my
gun on that i really wish i had my
lantern
i can't see a goddamn thing i'm going to
toss a flare
i've been robbing you
bang yeah yeah yeah you afraid of that
huh
you afraid of that i didn't put the
flare exactly where i wanted it to be
but that's okay
big man got a gun now yeah come on where
are you at i hear you
i hear you yeah you're not so scary
you're not so scary
you're not so scary
i'm not so scared you're not so scary
you're not so scared oh god you were
right in front of me
boom oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god how
did i screw that up that badly
come here come here come here come here
come here come here come here come here
where are you
come here just come here come here
where are you where are you where are
you
where are you oh my god oh it was right
there oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god next one i run okay that's
just the only answer where's my
running pills there's my running pills
next one i just run
this is out i think i i blew through
all of the ammo in that i don't know
what happened
i'm not gonna risk it being destroyed
that went
so terribly bad this is so many
mushrooms
i'm gonna have to go immediately home
after this
[Music]
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
return to the surf return to the return
to this where
am i returning to the surface where
exactly
oh um but about returning to the surface
is there a way out of the surface
um i seem to be stuck in the surface i
hear oh there you are you're i should
bring my torch out then i would be able
to see
ah there yeah that sounds oh i was like
oh there's a door
of course there's there's a door hello
excuse me
pardon me oh i know what house i'm in oh
cool plastic chickens is that
multiple plastic chickens oh god i keep
not clicking on the things that have
like a one uh consumable can i eat this
eat lungs are more efficient okay so
food makes your lungs more efficient
all right you know i have 12 mushrooms
oh my god
12. i'll take it but i'm sure i'm gonna
get more stuff
that's more valuable dog tag
[Music]
mamma mia here i go again
hello hi hi hi hi more eggs
give me all your eggs i want all of your
eggs
i don't know oh he covered in chicken
feces
oh that's what i need the chicken feces
i should have known that wasn't gonna go
in my inventory
all right i need to go cook these
mushrooms or else they're gonna degrade
i've gotten so many
so i'm gonna go cook them real quick and
then i'm going to come back hoof that
was
terrifying that well was horrifying the
pistol
god i cannot panic fire that thing i
should have just shoveled because
it seemed like one shovel was all it
took to kill those things this game man
this game i tell you
i love it i love this i i cannot believe
i waited this long to play this game
it's so good like that's the thing it's
so good at first like i thought the
controls were very clunky
but now it's like i i i love how it
controls
not because it controls like super well
or the controls are very tight but
because it makes sense
and because what it gives everything i
do a feeling of weight
and it gives a feeling of importance
that every action is like
essential i i really love this game
repair
the shovel i need to figure out what the
hell is with the pistol
do i put it in my hand and then reload
it
yep that's it all right that's all i
needed to do it was not broken it was
just
almost empty okay and i need to cook
everything absolutely
a 12. well i'm gonna go for another ride
probably uh oh oh once a day for about a
minute
i'll be able to see all around me okay
i'm not gonna get acid blood because i
don't intend to get
hit ever again
open up my third eye that just sounds
fun
all right cool 2400 2400 dose
efficiency of four i don't even know
what that means i don't even know what
that means
upgrade item i don't think i can light
materials
no i'm gonna go for the sturdy blade if
if anything at all
i don't even know if i'm going to
upgrade that again the flares were
useful
especially in the dark but i just didn't
do it right i didn't do
nothing right in that encounter i didn't
do anything right i'm actually don't
need to carry
that much ammo on me because hopefully
i'll actually hit my shots this time but
jury's out on whether that's actually
gonna be a thing we gotta go we gotta go
we gotta go back to the chicken lady
there should be just enough time to do
something
whatever it is whatever i wanna do
whatever i want to do i can do whatever
i want it's my life
my world just cause it's a little dark
in the woods doesn't mean that i
i can't have fun know what i mean you
know what i mean
you blow up don't i don't trust you i
could throw a rock at it couldn't i
throw a rock at it and see if it blows
up
couldn't one didn't one of these guys
have a rock oh
that's that would make so much sense did
i give you my rock
leave it around your exposed crotch
hello hi hello hi how are you
hello hi do you have anything to say
said the next little hen with an odd
little shrug i wish i could find a fat
little bug what do you want okay you
know what never mind
i have to um no oh that's right i needed
to give
it wasn't it wasn't for me oh yeah
that's right
i completely forgot about that
oh good that's good that's good that's
great
it wasn't for me oh but then the dilemma
do i give it to him
cause this is clearly not okay
oh steering wheel good oh god what do i
do
oh god what do i do
oh what do i do oh what do i do because
i got the key probably to that door and
i could open it right now but is that
gonna oh god i'm all the way over oh no
oh my god okay the boy revealed to me
that i will find a spare key to the
locker room in the chicken ladies house
sounds absurd but it's the only lead i
have the boy really with the old woman
with
asked me to find a key to her room he
will wait for me in his hideout
okay you know what it's not my business
what that kid thinks love is
and i'm not 100 sure it's good to even
give the key but
hey i just gotta do what i gotta do
and uh it is what it is you know what
i'm not i'm not
oh god but i want to go in the room
but i don't want to go in the room
the wolf asked me to bring him the key
to the locker room in the house the hag
that reeks of chickens
in exchange for this favor he will help
me retrieve a key a key for a key seems
quite fair
i shall find the hag in the villa this
is the same
key that they both want oh god they
both want this key okay let me think
this logically
if i open the door it probably will use
the key
i don't know if i've gotten too many
keys i mean would it use the key
i don't know i'm not 100 sure but
i feel like that would give me the best
idea of
what the situation is because if
she's like some horrible monster then if
i give the key to the kid
i suspect he's gonna die
oh i hate that
oh that sounds
awful okay look i don't want to risk
losing the key
i've got enough of an idea of what's
going on there if i give this to the kid
that kid's going to die i don't know
what the wolf man wants with this
situation
there's probably a whole metaphor about
wolf in the hen house or something like
that
but at the same time whatever's in there
ain't no pretty lady that i ever seen
okay that pretty lady i don't think
she's that pretty i'm just gonna go
ahead and say it
i don't think she's that pretty i'm
gonna give it to the wolf just because
the wolf is the one that said that he
could help me
find my key my key that's what i need
and the kid's just gonna get killed
young love
whatever it's fine it's bad idea
it's a terrible idea
oh you're back hey mind if i give you a
finality whump
here that's the lump you need that was
the lump you needed
yeah look sorry kid this is for your own
good
there's no other way that i can see this
right there's no other way that i can
see this
the wolf number one has kind of been
helpful to me
number two that kid's not very good at
violin yeah i'm just gonna come out and
say it
that kid doesn't really have a future in
violin
hey a wolf man yes meat i got a key
i'm doing this i'm committing as i
produce the key the wolf's pupils
widen with excitement well me i didn't
think you could succeed
i'm impressed time for your reward
you'll find that quack thief here
but he locked himself away from the
world and he won't let anyone in
so i don't know if this information will
be any use to you meaty what the [ __ ]
are you looking at
i promise that i'll tell you where to
find him and i did did i tell you you'll
be able to get there
that's something else isn't it you
dick now get out of my sight meat i have
important business to attend to
if you're interested in continuing our
relationship look for me in the
northeastern edge of the old woods
i predict a tasty future together well
sinks his hand and deep into his pockets
here deliver this to that insane old
[ __ ] as a wave
thank you for her beautiful sister
oh oh god
oh no the wolf throws the head of a
chicken under my feet as i lift my gaze
i realize that the wolf is gone
okay can i at least open your crates
can i at least do that
could you at least give that to me no
nothing you didn't even eat your
bone all right i still stand by my
judgment what was in that room
was not okay the noises
was bad and if that wolf is going to
kill that thing
then that's fair you know that's fair
you know what totally fine
you know what actually before i end this
i'm going to go see what the results of
the actions are let's see
let's see what happened because i don't
know let's see
i don't know i don't hear any violin
anymore
oh i do okay i hear violin okay
and also i would like to say he did give
me what i needed
which was the location of the the dude
it doesn't matter if he doesn't think i
can get in
i know i can get in hello
hi oh lordy what curse is falling upon
us
sweet mother what devilry one day janet
goes missing the next
me sister disappears oh lordy lordy
mister
have mercy upon me and find her mother
mary i don't know what i'm gonna do
without her all by myself
chickenhead jesus almighty my little
darling what have they done to you
this is a bad sign mr a bad sign what'll
happen now
you know what i don't trust you you may
seem like a kindly old chicken lady but
i don't trust you at all okay
a millet um a mil
a military fl a military
a military flag a military flashlight
the whole bed's gone a pile of crumpled
pillows and pillow cases it looks like
someone has slept here
bizarre a sheet and a few pairs of worn
trousers okay
so the answer is not just a bloody heap
which is interesting the answer is
the whole bed's just gone maybe the wolf
and that lady
are two peas in a pod maybe they're
meant for each other
maybe i got the true love ending after
all
yeah yeah yeah i think that is exactly
what's happening here
i feel good about what i did and how i
did it i feel great actually
okay so with that i'll end it here we
have
probably a little bit of time to go
explore one or two more things but then
we got to get back for another night
cycle so
thank you everybody so much for watching
i am loving this game
just absolutely loving it i don't know
if i made the right choice but i made
the choice the best i could with the gut
that i had and i have a funny feeling
that probably in this game
no choices are good so thank you and as
always
i'll see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you